38 eurofighter fliegen derzeit von hier
und der stützpunkt ist
ausbildungszentrum
ausbildungszentrum hier werden alle
deutschen eurofighter piloten und
pilotinnen ausgebildet und auch eine
alarmrotte ist hier stationiert und es
gibt nur zwei pilotinnen die eurofighter
fliegen bei der luftwaffe und eine davon
begrüße ich jetzt sehr herzlich petra es
noch mal herzlich willkommen
aus sicherheitsgründen keine nachnamen
hier von ihnen in der sendung und sie
sind ja hauptmann man sagt also immer
noch hauptmann bei der bundeswehr obwohl
sie eine frau sind als pilotin ist noch
schon noch exotinnen bei der luftwaffe
oder ja das ist richtig also wie sie
bereits sagten das sind nur zwei
kampfjet piloten auf den eurofighter
aktuell eingesetzt wir haben neben dem
eurofighter noch den kampfjet tornado
dort gibt es aktuell keine frau was hat
sich denn seit dem angriff russlands auf
die ganze ukraine im februar bei ihnen
geändert im job alltag aber vielleicht
auch in ihrer haltung als pilotin als
soldatin also man stellt sich seitdem
natürlich häufiger die frage was wäre
wenn es tatsächlich zum einsatz kommen
würde auch in der familie unter freunden
kommt diese frage jetzt häufiger vor
gerade daran durch die medien alltäglich
vor augen geführt bekommt dass der
frieden in dem wir jetzt seit jahren
leben und auch die art und weise wie wir
halt in deutschland leben können gar
nicht so selbstverständlich ist aber sie
haben ja wahrscheinlich schon lange
davor irgendwann für sich persönlich
entschieden dass sie als als soldaten im
ernstfall für ihr land töten und für ihr
land sterben
wollen das sind selbstverständlich
fragen welche man sich spätestens oder
halt frühestens bei dienstantritt
erstellen sollte und mit dem man sich
natürlich auch tiefgehend beschäftigt
hat wie sind sie damit umgegangen
letztendlich vertritt die bundeswehr
werte welche für welche ich natürlich
einstehe und welche ich auch schützen
möchte gerade was halt den frieden
angeht die art und weise wie wir eben
leben können und dass jeder am ende
seiner meinung frei äußern kann und so
leben kann wie er möchte das sind ja
ganz grundlegend und schwere fragen und
auch der job als pilotin als eurofighter
piloten ist ja eine unglaubliche
anstrengung ich durfte das ein stück
weit miterleben letzte woche weil ich in
einem eurofighter mitfliegen durfte und
ich kann ihnen sagen das war eine
grenzerfahrung
es ist ein job an den grenzen der
körperlichen und psychischen belastung
ich erlebe was es bedeutet im kampfjet
zu fliegen
schon der start ist extrem
es gibt senkrecht nach oben
das einzige ausbildungs geschwader der
deutschen luftwaffe für den eurofighter
am standort rostock laage werden piloten
geschult für den ernstfall
vor dem start ein muss das wetter
briefing es sieht gut aus für die
trainingsmission ich bin bei den aces
der ersten fliegerstaffel eingeteilt
formations führer andreas erläutert den
plan für sein hinter uns quasi
auszurollen und eine meile 1 2 kilometer
also dass er von dort eine kommode
abfang position hat die kampfjets werden
sich sehr nahe kommen mein pilot stefan
fliegt seit 28 jahren und bildet
inzwischen auch piloten aus
was wäre der wichtigste ratschlag für
mich
also am wichtigsten wäre erstmal mir
vertrauen genau was wir machen mein
beruf hat einen ernsten hintergrund das
hat nicht immer oder sehr selten was mit
spaß zu tun
eine alarmrotte ist derzeit ein
stützpunkt rostock laage stationiert sie
soll den luftraum über norddeutschland
schützen täglich üben sie den ernstfall
unbekannte flugzeuge abfangen
38 eurofighter starten derzeit vom
stützpunkt in rostock laage der
hauptauftrag ausbildung von piloten und
technikern
vorbereitungen für meinen mitflug die
anti g hose soll durch kompression eine
ohnmacht verhindern wenn die belastung
im eurofighter zu groß werde wir gehen
ohne munition in die luft seit beginn
des ukraine krieges hat sich der ernst
der lage für sie geändert erzählt stefan
jetzt neuerdings natürlich auch immer
öfter das mal russische luftfahrzeuge
auch im internationalen luftraum sich
annähernd über der ostsee die dann eben
auch begleitet werden ich habe keine
angst wiener war angespannt
für die piloten ist all dies routine sie
trainieren täglich damit sie im
richtigen moment in sekundenschnelle
reagieren schon beim start wirken
gewaltige kräfte aufs cockpit und auf
den körper
[Musik]
bei loopings und überschlägen lastet ein
mehrfaches des eigenen körpergewichts
auf uns
jetzt dreht sich das werden nach vorne
mit rund 1.200 stundenkilometern durch
die luft mich erstaunt die ruhe mit der
mein pilot diese extremsituation
meistert die routine gibt den männern
und frauen im cockpit halt für diesen
extremen berufen und trotzdem der
ernstfall ist da russlands angriff auf
die ukraine für alle näher gerückt
nach einer stunde landen wir ich habe es
gut überstanden
ein wenig schwierig ist mir schon
es ist unvorstellbar und
dann im ernstfall
präsent zu sein und und und die
richtigen entscheidungen zu treffen und
das ist eine unglaubliche anstrengung
nur ein kleiner einblick aber er hilft
zu verstehen was die menschen bewegt die
in diesen zeiten uniform tragen ich
glaube man hat gesehen dass ich fand es
ziemlich heftig aber es war natürlich
auch hochinteressant das mal mit zu
erleben wir wollen die runde ich ein
bisschen erweitern und ich begrüße jetzt
noch mal ganz herzlich den chef dieses
stützpunktes hier in rostock laage den
commodore joachim kaske noch mal
herzlich willkommen
herr caspar sie haben sich ja auch so
ein bisschen begleitet und vorbereitet
auf den flug letzte woche und ich konnte
hier ein paar einblicke gewinnen und
mein gefühl war es ist eine unglaubliche
routine und professionalität her hier
aber auch ein stück weit ich will es
vielleicht nicht sagen verunsicherung
aber man macht sich schon gedanken auch
was jetzt diese neue situation nach dem
angriff russlands auf die ganze ukraine
seit februar auch für sie persönlich
bedeutet sind das den gedanken
gefühle vielleicht auch sorgen die sie
mit ihren mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeitern hier auf dem stützpunkt
auch mal besprechen
ich glaube kommunikation ist alles in
einer demokratie und deswegen gehen wir
damit auch sehr offen um und sprechen
miteinander und diskutieren die dinge
auch sehr offen und klar ist bei dem
alle natürlich auch wie sie es gesagt
haben wir sind profis wir sind gut
vorbereitet wir sind gut ausgebildet
dass unser kernauftrag hier menschen wie
petra die hier gerade die ausbildung
durchlaufen haben da kann man dankbar
sein dass sich junge menschen
engagieren und bereits in unserem land
verantwortung zu übernehmen für
sicherheit und frieden und ja dem muss
man dem muss man raum geben und dann
aber gleichzeitig natürlich auch die
entschlossenheit haben dass wenn es wenn
es gefordert ist das natürlich auch dann
die entsprechende fähigkeiten abgerufen
werden können wir wollen ja bei dieser
sendung so müssen herausfinden wie sie
als soldatinnen und soldaten schicken
aber auch was ich so verschiebt bei der
bundeswehr aber auch in der gesellschaft
petra sie sind ja auch im alltag
unterwegs als als soldatin vielleicht
auch mal in uniform und werden
vielleicht auch angesprochen das haben
wir viele hier in diesen tagen erzählt
in rostock begegnet man denn ihnen seit
kriegsbeginn anders im alltag also daten
ich höre aber gerade und wir sehen es
auch hier das sind jetzt eurofighter die
staaten das ist hier vor unserer halle
und das sind herr kaske die erste nur um
flüge
[Applaus]
da halten sich selbst viele soldatinnen
und soldaten die daneben stehen die
ohren zu
er schnitt das sind
die flüge starten
[Musik]
jetzt kam ganz genau ist
ausbildung
als bei jungen
[Musik]
ausgebildet
und letztendlich erfordert viel und
schwierigen aufgaben die sie
letztendlich übernehmen können müssen
und jetzt jetzt
ich weiß nicht ob wir uns gut verstanden
hat aber ja ich höre man hat uns gut
verstanden jetzt sind sie schon weg und
wir können weiter sprechen petra ich
habe sie gerade gefragt ob man denn
ihnen im alltag wenn sie in uniform
unterwegs sind anders begegnet seit dem
angriff russlands auf die ganze ukraine
als vorher die hätte ich persönlich
finde das gegenüber der bundeswehr in
der gesellschaft tatsächlich ein
umdenken stattgefunden hat mir selber
wurde des öfteren in der vergangenheit
gesagt dass die leute vor sind das ist
die bundeswehr gibt diese meinung mag
zwar vorher schon fanden gewesen sein
allerdings wurde sie mir gegenüber eher
selten geäußert aber es gibt natürlich
auch kritiker und kritikerinnen was die
bundeswehr und was diese aus oder
aufrüstung der bundeswehr jetzt an geht
mir hatten wir auch heute morgen hier in
der sendung herr kaske das eine ist ja
dass viele dann doch bezweifeln dass
mehr waffen auch mehr frieden bringen
was sagen sie denen
ich glaube dass es im kern darum geht
dass junge menschen wie petra die sich
für ihren dienst in der luftwaffe
entschieden haben wenn ich es mal auf
die luftwaffe beziehen darf dann auch
die ausrüstung bekommen die sie brauchen
damit sie gut ausgebildet und gut
geschützt am ende für sicherheit und
frieden 1 stehen können und lassen sie
mich bei der gelegenheit zum schluss
unseres morgenmagazins weil wir so
langsam zum ende der sendezeit kommt
vielleicht eine persönliche anmerkung
machen ich darf seit knapp drei jahren
jetzt hier commodore sein ein
fantastisches team von über 1000
menschen die jeden tag an ihrer stelle
dafür einstehen dass es in unserem land
friedlich zugeht und dieser frieden und
diese ordnung auch erhalten werden kann
und dass eine unglaublich als dafür bin
ich unglaublich dankbar für dieses
engagement der vielen menschen die hier
in rostock laage tagtäglich dienst tun
will aber trotzdem noch mal bei der
kritik bleiben
das eine ist das was ich gerade gesagt
habe dass menschen diese neue
ausstattung oder aufrüstung auch
kritisch sehen das andere ist ja dass
die bundeswehr oft auch in der kritik
steht was das beschaffungswesen angeht
was verkrustete strukturen angeht also
nur mehr geld für eine bessere
ausrüstung reicht ja nicht um die
bundeswehr zu einer modernen armee zu
machen in jeder großen organisation gibt
es glaube ich immer luft nach oben sei
es in der kommunikation sei es in
strukturen diese dinge sind ja auch
angegangen die werden derzeit von der
politik bewegt werden von unseren
inspekteur gehört er das am beispiel und
auch schon fest gemacht hat und ja wir
müssen hier nach vorne schauen für uns
ist wichtig dass natürlich aber auch zu
alldem die finanziellen mittel hinzu
kommen weil wir schon auch nachholbedarf
haben und schauen müssen dass wir eben
am aktuellen rand der technologie auch
bleiben in beiden danke ich auf jeden
fall schon mal recht herzlich petra s
eurofighter pilot sinn und der kommodore
hier in rostock laage joachim kaske
vielen dank
und das war also unser mona vor ort hier
aus rostock laage es ging darum einen
einblick zu bekommen in die gedanken und
gefühlswelt der bundeswehr ist ging
darum viele verschiedene stimmen hier zu
hören wir haben festgestellt dass die
bundeswehr auch offen ist hierfür für
kritische stimmen und all das was wir
besprochen haben war glaube ich
interessant und kann man auch in der zdf
mediathek
nachschauen da verschiebt sich gerade
was bei der bundeswehr auch in der
gesellschaft und ich glaube es ist
wichtig und richtig dass wir das offen
aber auch kritisch und interessiert
begleiten also roma vor ort nach langer
zeit wieder wir hatten ja ausgesetzt
wegen der pandemie mit publikum und ich
habe mich sehr gefreut hier zu sein in
rostock laage bei der luftwaffe und gäbe
wieder zurück nach berlin mit